let's go next to frumpus from chicago
frumpus you're on the air
frankfurt you're on the air how are you
i'm doing all right thank you um so i
saw
um some other countries are testing out
a four
day work week have you heard of that yep
we covered that on the bonus show last
week
okay um so i'm thinking that
some states in the u.s should try this
um and i've seen some justifications
stating things like well the five day
work week was based on
one family member and the typical
household staying home and taking care
of things the one person being the bread
winner so
i was just wondering what you were
thinking of the justifications to move
to a
four-day work week um i i've heard of
the productivity but i just
thought to get your comments on that
yeah what do you what do you when you
say states should try it do you mean
states should mandate that businesses
only have people work four days or you
mean like state employees should do it
that's a that's a good distinction i was
thinking it was just a labor law
um within a certain state um
yeah that's never gonna happen but let's
let's put that aside i mean it's not
gonna happen anytime soon let's put that
aside
sure here's why i think four four day a
week is is very interesting
there's a real difference between having
two days off
versus three days off a week and when
you have the three days off and you've
got that middle day where you were off
yesterday and you're off tomorrow
i think that psychologically there's a
massive benefit to that
and the benefit to that is that then
people are more
productive on the four days that they
are working even if in total they're
working slightly
fewer hours we've sort of adopted this
at the david pakman show in that we film
our five
shows each week in four days so like
we're we're not off on friday but it's
sort of like a
ketchup administrative work you know
everybody has the stuff we work on on
fridays but like
the core filming is all happening four
days a week and i know for me
psychologically
when we're done on thursday it's like oh
i'm not doing like
a core filming day friday saturday or
sunday that's really great and i think
it makes me significantly more
productive monday monday through
thursday
if i had child care considerations i
think it would be
uh significantly uh more convenient and
also cheaper from the standpoint of
child care
if i have three days and then my
significant other has three days
i think that there's significant
benefits there uh but yeah i don't think
there's anything magical about a five
day a week work week and the the study
that we looked at
last week on the bonus show uh was very
positive as far as that goes
okay well god knows i could use another
day um thanks for taking my call
producer pat's doing okay talk to you
later all right my pleasure thank you
very much